grâce aux techniques modernes et aux
progrès de la science
les français se soigne de mieux en mieux
en disant l'argent qu'ils ont consacré à
leur santé a doublé déficit de la
sécurité sociale
en 1970 un milliard de francs dans cinq
ans ce déficit risque d'atteindre 10
milliards en 1967 pourtant à voter des
ordonnances pour résorber en partie ce
déficit
alors que s'est-il passé ce que les
ordonnances ont échoué et bien en
réalité les ordonnances n'ont pas échoué
puisque l on avis petit un freinage de
la dépense puisque en 1969
l'ensemble des prestations sociales de
la nation n'ont pas de déficit elles
sont tannés qui lie c'est un progrès
considérable car le cinquième plan avait
prévu un déficit d'une très grande
importance en 1969 seulement le problème
c'est que l'ensemble des prestations
croît de 12 % par an et que les
ressources augmentent d'environ 6% par
an il ya donc là une de distorsion qui
aboutit à un accroissement permanent des
dépenses et il faut maintenant alors
chercher un certain nombre de solutions
qui ne soient plus provisoire mais dans
la perspective du sixième plan beaucoup
de français se posent la question
suivante est il normal qu'un salarié
qu'il ya une cuisse en francs par mois
cotisent surtout son salaire qu'à
salariés qu'il ya une 300 mille francs
par mois 300 mille anciens francs
cotisent simplement sur la moitié de son
salaire
oui c'est le problème du déplafonnement
vous savez que nous sommes dans une
période actuellement de concertation de
dialogue puisque il ya des commissions
qui siège dans le cadre du sixième plan
et qui sont très nombreux et ses
commissions expriment leur avis ce qui
est tout à fait nature alors il ya eu
une proposition tendant à déplafonner la
dépense en matière de maladies je dis en
passant que cela n'a aucune incidence
sur la vieillesse donc sur les retraites
deux cas il ya une émotion qui sait a
été soulevé à cette occasion qui sans
porter puisque telle n'est pas la
proposition de porter atteinte aux
retraites de calmer un effet une des
commissions du sixième plan a proposé de
déplafonner pour la mallette je vous
avoue que le gouvernement n'a pas dû
tout arrêter sa position dans cette
affaire puisque nous sommes au stade du
dialogue et de la concertation mais que
n'est pas anormal d'envisager en effet
une proportion de la cotisation à la
maladie qu'ils soient si non
proportionnelles au salaire du moins
augmenter en fonction de l'importance
des salaires il est tout à fait légitime
que quelqu'un qui a eu trois cent mille
francs par mois pour reprendre votre
expression paie davantage que celui qui
gagne 150 mille francs par mois
justement face au dossier explosif de la
sécurité sociale quelles sont les
mesures qu'il préconise actuellement
gouvernement est bien le gouvernement
pour l'instant on est au stade de la
réflexion et des propositions et en
l'état actuel des choses le gouvernement
se borne à recevoir ses avis et
propositions et n'a pas pris lui-même de
position sur aucun des probables alors
il y aura évidemment une deuxième phase
dans lequel le gouvernement et moi-même
d'abord ferai un certain nombre de
propositions
les orientations que l'on peut voir
c'est que il faudra faire une politique
familiale plus hardis du fait que nous
sommes dans une phase d nathalie ce
qu'il faudra sûrement faire un effort à
l'égard de la vieillesse parce que le
nombre de nos vieux augment et qu'il
nous faut faire l'effort prioritaire en
matière de vieillesse et il est
vraisemblable alors que si on veut
ajuster les recettes aux dépenses et ne
pas ruiner le système de la sécurité
sociale qu'il faudra freiner les
dépenses générales de maladie et qu'il
faudra proposer un certain nombre de
solutions non pas du tout pour moins
bien soignés les français mais pour
éviter ce qui est excessif ce qui est
abusif et faire que l'argent des deniers
publics soient le mieux employé possible